il est leur parler de sony savez sony
continue à renouveler sa gamme des
xperia world on a eu pas mal de
smartphones il a cette année on a
l'expérience 5
ce que vous l'avez naître comme ça la
petite boîte blanche xperia 5 et
l'xperia 5
il est vraiment intéressant c'est une
des meilleures propositions qu'a fait
toni depuis très longtemps
ils ont toujours des trucs vraiment
intéressant ce lien les écrans sont
vraiment bien il ya un gros travail en
fait c'est ce que je vous dis à chaque
fois sony vous avez des choses qui sont
maîtrisés de tous les côtés vous avez
chose qui est vraiment bien des beaux
écrans bravia oled ça marche ils ont une
vraie savoir faire au niveau des caméras
ils ont les sony alpha qui sont vraiment
bien ils ont une expertise dans le jeu
vidéo qui est incroyable avec
playstation
ils ont une marque qui est énorme et de
tous les côtés et ils ont du mal et
c'est vraiment d'arriver avec les
smartphones et avec ce petit smartphone
la fin petit très long surtout ils ont
une proposition de valeur qui est
vraiment intéressante
on va se mettre derrière on va regarder
ça ensemble et je contourne birman
commentaires que vous en pensez
[Musique]
regardez-moi sa jolie petite boîte
expérience sans expression doit bien
faire en fait comme ça à selim à nice en
fait comme moi je sais pas pourquoi est
ce que sony se dit on va faire des
boîtes très minimaliste voyez ce côté là
c'est pas xperia 5 xperia cinq ex paria
il n'y a pas grand choses m'ont mise à
part qu'elle a déjà vécu parce que c'est
une boîte de presse donc vous voyez là
déjà fait sa petite vie il ya rien de
bien bien bien d'un gros lorsque vous
l'ouvrez vous avez un carton ça je pense
que c'est un effet un peu cartoon et
celle du recyclé vous avez des petites
documentation un petit bloc de charge 18
watts charge rapide vidéo a directement
en usb c'est là que vous avez invité un
parle à mon petit lapin des écouteurs
avec une prise jack ça on va en parler
il ya un truc que je suis pas hyper fan
on en parlait ici quelques temps je me
levais de côté sommes pas là bas on a
ensuite on en parle aussi d'ailleurs ça
c'est pour la prise jack et ici on a de
l'usbc usb c'est pour venir recharger
votre batterie
voilà pour la boîte voilà la bête xperia
5 alors mois déjà à ce que j'aime et je
trouve vraiment très intéressant c'est
que vous avez une proposition de valeur
qui est différente par rapport au reste
de la concurrence on est sur un
smartphone très long on a un écran aucun
format 21/9 message revient dessus dans
quelques temps le format pour la prise
en main est vraiment bien par contre
attention c'est un smartphone qui est
très glissant c'est une vraie petite
savonnette malgré ça vous avez un
corning gorilla glass 6 à l'arrière mais
également à l'avant ça veut pas dire
qu'il est un cas ça veut pas dire qu'il
résistera à tous je trouve en tout cas
moi vraiment cool parce que voyez vous
pouvez le faire le tour comme ça à une
seule main et ça c'est vraiment rare
aujourd'hui les smartphones tout ça
c'est une propulsion de valeur qui est
vraiment intéressant qui est vraiment
différenciante et rien que pour ça sony
jetons ça vraiment bien
164 g il est pas très très lourd et il
ya un truc qui est un peu surprenant qui
pourrait être un peu bizarre c'est qu'en
fait vous avez tous les boutons qui sont
logés du même côté
là ce sont les boutons de volume pour
monter et baisser le son serviront
également de zoom lorsqu'on veut faire
des photos mais sans voix pendant
quelques instants le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
le bouton pour l'allumer et pour
l'éteindre et ici un bouton qui vous
servira prendre des photos sans notion
de ça peut être très très esthétiques
sont vraiment bien réussi métal chromé
c'est très bien ce haut parleur
je trouve vraiment très très beau ça
vraiment super beau boulot de l'usbc le
micro de ce côté là et c'est aussi assez
surprenant vous avez la place pour votre
double na no 6 mo alors na no 6 mai
carte micro sd et vous n'avez pas sommes
de petits pics pour l'enlever vous êtes
petite encoche vous le prenez tac
regardez ça ça c'est rigolo parce que ça
bouge comme ça donc
pas de les casser enfin en tout cas si
on y va normalement ça devrait plutôt
bien se passer
vous luttez si votre carte sim principal
deuxième sim ici ou alors la carte micro
sd peut monter jusqu'à 512 go de
stockage mais ça on en parle aussi dans
quelques instants tandis que ce soir
dessus et bien vous avez juste votre
micro pour la réduction de bruit à
l'arrière trip module photo on en parle
ce n'est quelques instants le flash led
le branding sony xperia ici la petite
non ce qui est là mais qu'on ne voit pas
très bien ils ont voulu flanquer un peu
ça marche après son décès moi je le
trouve en tout cas d'imprévu ses tics
vraiment très sympa rumba et
effectivement on a une grande bordure
sur l'eau qui va dire et cueillir le
haut parleur la caméra et les différents
capteurs là ok on a effectivement aussi
une bordure sur le bas on a
effectivement ces deux partis là ça fait
partie de son adn c'est pas très grave
c'est pas très embêtant je trouve ça
bien en fait que sony cherche à nous
proposer quelque chose de différent
ne pas chercher à faire comme tout le
monde ne pas avoir le même smartphone ne
pas voir la même copie de rester dans
son adn et de s'appuyer sur ce qui fait
le succès de la marque
et justement puisqu'on parle de succès
la marque on va parler de l' écran
bravia oled qui est une des références
chez sony et des très beaux écrans au
niveau des téléviseurs chez sony
justement il réplique leurs technologies
à quelque chose près d'un smartphone 6,1
pouces de pur bonheur 21/9 de pur
bonheur 2520 par 1080 pixels vous avez
un écran qui est vraiment bien très bien
calibrée très bien maîtrisé ça c'est
vraiment des gros gros gros gros gros
gros gros point fort de la part de sony
calibré dans vos paramètres vous allez
dans affichage pouvait venir tout régler
réglez la qualité de l'image soit en
mode standard soit en mode créateur bon
là vous allez consommer un peu plus de
batterie vous allez aller plus loin en
termes de qualité néanmoins rester en
mode standard
gardez vous avez un mode créateur
automatique qui va vous switchez
automatiquement lorsque vous en aurez
besoin
de la même manière pour venir régler la
balance des blancs un peu plus froide
quoi faire un peu plus de bleu un peu
plus de show why not
ou alors s'ils n'ont pas carrément venir
le régler vous directement puisqu'on
fracture du côté de l'ol on tourne sur
un android 9 paille on reste dans le
côté multimédia on va faire un tour du
côté de la doxa c'est vachement
intéressant vous avez donc deux haut
parleurs un haut parleur qui se situe là
et un deuxième haut parleurs on va
utiliser les haut parleurs vous avez en
face à dc haut parleurs stéréo ldlc
qualcomm a pété x hd on a vraiment
quelque chose qui est parfait pour le 2
qui marche très bien alors effectivement
lorsque vous allez regarder une série
que vous allez écouter de la musique aux
côtés de la musique comme ça directement
tout seul sans casque bon c'est un petit
peu bizarre mais pourquoi pas mais
lorsque vous mettez sur youtube sur
netflix sur ce que vous voulez eh bien
expérience audio est vraiment bien si
vous le poussez vraiment trop fort dans
l'air franchement on peut perdre un peu
en qualité mais je trouve que dans
l'absolu c'est déséquilibré
saint-georges bien aux castes ça marche
très très bien
et comme vous l'avez remarqué ici il n'y
a absolument pas de président jacques
alors vous m'expliquez sony pourquoi est
ce que vous faites ça ça pour moi c'est
pas un bon choix c'est à dire qu'on est
un smartphone qui n'a pas de prise
directe et qu'est ce qu'on nous met dans
la boîte et bien des écouteurs avec une
prise jack
ok alors ok je sais je sais si on va
chercher un peu plus loin on va se
retrouver avec ce petit accessoire là
vous avez l'adaptateur triste jack usb
c'est pour venir brancher la mesa une
fois de plus je le dis je leur dis et je
le redis je le signe je persiste c'est
une hérésie que vous avez branché dans
votre smartphone en adaptateurs en iran
suite brancher le casque qui est fourni
avec
donc il faut m'expliquer pourquoi est-ce
qu'on va adapter un truc qui font
directement que le smartphone la moment
ça a plus de sens pourquoi pas
directement fournir des écouteurs qui
vont se brancher en usb c'est alors on
pourrait me dire effectivement on peut
vouloir utiliser son petit casque dans
d'autres appareils qui eux par contre
une prise jack mais franchement je suis
pas sûr qu'on ait envie d'utiliser sa
part tout c'est pas pour est à plus de
sens on fait ce qu'il faut
lorsque vous utilisez ce smartphone
c'est tout simplement de prendre un
casque en la matière je conseille
notamment le whh mais l'ex n 3 de sony
j'utilise moi à titre personnel depuis
tiens donc je trouve vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool ils font vraiment un super
boulot sur le dos je vous disais
effectivement que sony est partout les
écrans les consoles le jo on retrouve
son nid dans plein d'univers l'appareil
photo enfin voila c'est vraiment
vraiment énorme
donc en fait il n'ya pas deux prises
jack vous en mettez pas à vouloir voir
quelque chose avec une prise jack
utiliser si vous pouvez pas vous le
permettre
un casque comme ça à l'adduction bruit
notamment le wh1 1033 qui est vraiment
très très bien
sans tout cas ça va augmenter le côté
expérientiel de votre smartphone mois
sur la partie audio je suis vraiment
compris ça marche bien le son est
vraiment cool clair assez limpide c'est
vraiment vraiment bonne qualité côté
purement expérientiel c'est vraiment
bien il ya le truc est vraiment agaçant
côté purement expérientiel ce sont les
vibrations dynamique alors là s'adapte à
youtube ça peut être aussi adapté
netflix
pourquoi que ça va faire c'est ça va
faire vibrer votre smartphone en
fonction de la musique en fonction du
son vous allez avoir j'ai plusieurs
niveaux au niveau 1 niveau 2 niveau 3
plus jeunes ont plus le smartphone va
vibrer fort alors là effectivement on
est sur une vidéo youtube et si vous
mettez sur un tout netflix un peu un
film d'action et bien vous allez sentir
la vibration dans votre smartphone ça
peut être pas mal moins
suit pas il pratiquera fans parce que
déjà six volets comme un naturel les
vibrations dans les mains je les ai sans
avoir de téléphone dont je m'en
passerais largement puisque mais dans le
côté puissance expérientiel vous avez un
truc est vraiment intéressant pour le
mode gaming arrive vous avez une petite
partie ici c'est l'optimisateur de jeu
vous allez pouvoir revenir complètement
optimiser votre smartphone pour votre
jeu performance privilégié autonomie de
la batterie ça ça dépend effectivement
ce qui vous reste en terme de deux
batteries si vous voulez tirer un peu
dessus ou pas vous avez ensuite le
réglage des priorités pour les libérer
de la ram basque identification masqué
notification d'appel ont pas mal de
petits réglages ça se fait beaucoup
aujourd'hui tous à venir enregistrer
directement votre écran en session de
jeu côté performances on a quasiment ce
qui séduit aujourd'hui qualcomm
snapdragon 855 ici pas que 155 plus mais
ça fait quand même le taf
si giga de ram sens et physique à
stockage pourrait monter jusqu'à 512 go
de stockage
ce que je vais leur projet que je trouve
qu'il a tendance un petit peu trop à
chauffer à cette partie là la rouille
dans la partie du haut lorsque vous avez
des sessions de jeu qui sont peu
prolongée est bien là là toute cette
partie là il est chaud alors ça peut
être intéressant en hiver parce que ça
va effectivement venir vont réchauffer
les mains
mais lorsque vous jouez comme ça c'est
parce qu'être plus agréable d'un point
de vue purement expérientiel en tout cas
tout ça vraiment bien c'est assez fluide
avec le stade ragots du 155 surtout vous
avez un score 2 364 1761 qui va le
positionner quasiment même score que le
mec vins produits huawei vous pouvez
faire du multitâche
alors je sais pas si vous utilisez
multitâche l'appel ça ici le mode multi
fenêtres 21/9 regarder un film gérer des
emails à voir le mahb samba
effectivement l'écran est assez grand ça
peut se faire
est ce que maintenant quelqu'un le fait
personnellement j'en suis pas persuadé
on retrouve une batterie de 3140
milliampères heures avec une recharge
rapide de 18 watts qui vous permet de
tenir jusqu'à deux jours sans aucun
problème passons maintenant à la partie
photo parce que c'est au final ce qui
nous intéresse en tout cas un des sujets
qui nous intéressent le plus vous avez
trois capteurs vous les voyez ici ils
sont alignés forcément peut pas les
louper je vous sens d'ailleurs plutôt
bien fait has been alignés vous avez 3
capteur de 12 mégapixels 12 12 12
on vous avait 12 mégapixels en
équivalent 52 mm c'est un téléobjectif
ouvre à f 2.4 qui elle a porté
l'objectif est pour le mode portrait en
dessous vous avez bien évidemment une
fois de plus vous en douterez 1 12
mégapixels équivalent 26 mm c'est votre
objectif standard qu'une ouverture de f
1.76 tout en bas vous avez un 12 mai
pixel équivalent en 16 mm c'est un ultra
grand-angle qui ouvre à f 2.4 avec un
champ de vision de 130 degrés sur le 52
mm et les 26 mm vous avez la
stabilisation optique pour les photos
stabilisation optique plus électronique
pour la vidéo tandis que son ultra
grand-angle
eh bien vous ne l'avez pas ici vous
venez voir ici à l'avant on le voit vous
avez une petite caméra de cette fillette
planqueel a lu médiatique série qui
ouvre à f 2.0 un des points forts de
sonia des points forts de la marque
c'est la partie photo ils sont très très
fort là dessus il entend qui marche très
bien celle hytera qui nous regarde et je
sais pas si je suis là où je suis là
parce que je suis un peu de distance ça
me reconnais mon oeil et ça fait le faux
cul donc ça me suis complètement lorsque
je me déplace sa part mais effectivement
des toujours net ça vient vraiment
calibré l'oeil c'est bien vraiment
chercher le ça s'est vraiment bien ce
qui fait que je peux bouger directement
à droite à gauche m'avancer eh bien je
suis toujours nez de tous les côtés et
ça sert les points qui est énorme et à
des points qui marche vachement bien
du côté de sony du point de vue comme
aux vidéos vous avez l'application
cinéma pro alors l'application cinéma
pro elle fait une promesse qui est
vraiment très très très très très
intéressant c'est à dire que tout un
chacun va pouvoir filmer avec un outil
similaire aux outils professionnels je
trouve ça bien les promesses sont
intéressantes mais je pense que sa
personne va l'utiliser c'est très
compliqué mais ça paraît très simple à
utiliser au final il faut quand même
savoir régler
il faut que vous sachiez régler vos iso
votre obturateur juin notre objectif
parce que plus compliquée faut faire une
bonne balance des blancs votre mise au
point ensuite je peux venir choisir mes
looks samir me changer un petit peu la
couleur dans l'image
si vous êtes semi professionnel et que
vous voulez vous amuser avec un
smartphone vous voulez filer plein de
choses et vous vous y connaissez dans
les réglages ça peut avoir un sens
maintenant vous ne connaissez absolument
rien je pense que là dessus vous avez
galéré pendant un petit moment
vous pouvez donc filmer au format 21
9ème je sais pas si ça apporte vraiment
grand-chose de filmeur 21/9 il est en
tout cas si vous voulez faire vous
pouvez le faire il fait donc des
promesses qui sont vraiment pas mal au
niveau de la photo mais ce que je
propose c'est juste un petit coup d'oeil
directement pour voir si le résultat est
là on va regarder ça ensemble et vous
allez bien sûr qu'ils sont vraiment très
intéressantes d'autres un petit peu
moins bien là à l'extérieur on est à
paris
on est rudement bas capteur principal
équivalent 26 mm une bonne gestion des
lumières global on a un détail qui est
plutôt de bien plutôt maîtrisé ça marche
bien on va ensuite sur le zoom x 2 zoom
optique c'est maîtrisé s'est stabilisée
s'écoule et des combats sont ultra
grand-angle à une petite différence de
colorimétrie mais ça fait son effet on
n'est pas des formes en son côté une
belle correction d'un point de vue
purement logicielle le rendu est là ça
marche
j'ai ensuite vous aimiez que le zoom x
glisse alors voyez on fait quelque chose
on sort quelque chose mais c'est
vraiment pas hyper qualif j'ai fait
exprès à vous prendre le soleil en haut
des bâtiments ça marche je continue avec
le zoom x 2 ultra grand-angle marche
bien j'ai atterri dans des conditions de
faible luminosité
là c'est un petit peu moins bien et
voyez j'ai beau avoir une stabilisation
je trouve qu'ils galèrent un petit peu
une fois deux salissent c'est pas
terrible il a un qui peut de balle
tellement faible luminosité juste rag
renvoyer séparé l'année pas de
stabilisation c'est quand même
relativement floue et avec moi ça ne
pardonne absolument pas là appareil
photo standard et voyez toutes les
lumières sur le côté là la gestion de
lumière est pas belle la suite une fois
de séparer c'est la même chose lustres
avant tant de mots parlant pas un
appareil photo standard zoom x 2 ultra
grand-angle voyez des quais un petit peu
moins de lumière pour moi là il a un
petit peu de mal c'est vraiment pas là
où il va être le meilleur
jolie petite soupe chez etienne marcel
plutôt bien pour que voyez le le rendu
est assez cali même avec un zoom x 2 ça
fait le taf c'est pas ou peu mais ça
fait tâche et du travail en tant qu une
fois de plus on perd quand même un petit
peu en précision l'éléctro là plutôt
bien j'ai une foi de chez pas ce qui
s'est passé et on voit qu'on est
stabilisé l'a pas trop parce qu'il ya un
mouvement ultra grand-angle fait le taff
dès qu'on appelle lumière est là tout
avec les une fois distrayant plus le
métro commencent à partir
là le rendu tout de suite et paquets
lille camille cali du tout le joli petit
lapin qui marche bien en appareil photo
normale
zoom x 2 ça fait le taff ultra
grand-angle ça va ça fonctionne
cela vous est pris une vue avec le ciel
pour vraiment regarder le hdr regarder
on voit le soleil comprend en pleine
tronche on va pourtant bien les nuages
on a un beau détails
on voit bien toutes les façades avant il
ya un gars qui est cramé x 2 c'est
pareil ça marche plutôt pas mal
nous faut dix voiliers on a toujours cet
effet très lisse et pas très beau bon ça
c'est pas normal
l'élu ultra-grand-angle marche bien de
ce côté là le hdr marche bien
la belle plage dynamique ça c'est
vraiment cool voilà donc un smartphone
qui ont relativement bon pour les photos
dès lors vous avez belles conditions de
lumière quand il ya un petit peu moins
de lumière
il est un peu moins bon il a beau switch
est directement en mode nuit sous l'eau
rendue et moins qualitatif et canal at
elle fuit toute bonne qualité mais
globalement je dirais que d'un point de
vue purement phu tho ça marche
dès lors vous avez la lumière ça c'est
leur principe de la photo si apple
lumière ça marche un peu moins bien mais
tout ce qui va être photo
et ça c'est un petit peu un petit peu
limite limite et notamment quand on
parle des propositions tarifaires en
face vous êtes quand même à 799 euros
si vous regardez ce que vous allez
pouvoir trouver en face du côté de
chihuahua notamment avec le patron pro
ou alors carrément avec google pixels 4
alors c'est pas la même chose vous avez
des créateurs de bmc pas le même
principe pas le même truc est bien en
photo nuit ils sont un petit peu la
traîne ça ça peut être en tout cas
relativement dommage usages multimédias
pour moi vous avez un truc est vraiment
vraiment bien vraiment intéressant
superbe écran très bien calibrée le jo
il vraiment de bonne qualité immersif le
fait d'avoir les vibrations pourquoi pas
ça peut être intéressant vous avez la
performance pour gainey n'a rien dans
tous les réseaux sociaux c'est pareil ce
grand écran 21/9 c'est vraiment bien
notamment pour instagram pour venir
naviguer dedans ça chauffe ça très très
cool donc tout l'aspect multimédia
divertissement ça marche bien c'est à
côté de ça vous avez du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé c'est un
smartphone qui est certifié résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière ip 65 et 68
voilà donc pour ce test sony xperia cinq
mois j'aime beaucoup je trouve vraiment
intéressant il n'est pas encore parfait
il va avoir quelques difficultés
notamment au niveau du tarif 799 euros
il est vraiment prêt michelin entre nos
côtés les flagships killer et de côté le
très haut de gamme
donc c'est pas hyper évident en terme de
positionnement à côté de ça vous avez
smartphones qui est très performant
qu'une propose une valeur qui est quand
même relativement différente je trouve
que sony pour le coup en 2019 trouve sa
place vraiment dans l'univers du
smartphone est ce que maintenant le
public va répondre
est ce que le public va être intéressé
par un écran 21/9 par ce format là ça
c'est autre chose par contre moi j'aime
bien je trouve que sony vous avez fait
un super boulot avec ce smartphone
vraiment bien là par contre il faut
protéger parce que c'est une très petite
savonnette il commence un petit peu de
trois lycées il est à côté de ça je
trouve vraiment intéressant et je vous
dis je pense qu'il va intéresser pas mal
de monde c'est moi s'il vous plaît
comment vous le trouvez qu est ce que
vous pensez de cette proposition de
valeur avec son xperia 5 en 2019 quitte
moi s'ils peuvent ou tenter si
d'ailleurs vous avez un smartphone 2 de
sony ou si vous n'avez eu un et si oui
lequel s et lequel était si oui on s'en
fait de la conjugaison en même temps
marc coma tous en banque au mental quand
on se retrouve dès demain pour étudier
par les take the mask